elles ont fleuri sur les poteaux bien
avant les bourgeons sur les branches et
l offre ce printemps aux électeurs le
bouquet de candidat le plus fourni de
leur histoire 12 visages sur des
affiches ils tentent de prendre le siège
laissé vacant par catherine fournier
l'ex député est devenu en novembre
mairesse de la ville de longueuil dont
marie victorin représentent un dixième
de la superficie
mais un quart de la population
françois legault qui a laissé passer
l'hiver avant d'organiser l'élection la
voient comme un test je pense qu'un test
d'avant pour le parti québécois il faut
dire que la coloration historique et
sans équivoque ou presque sur 13 scrutin
un seul à échapper au pq au profit des
libéraux
ceux qui se dégradent surtout en
élection partielle c'est le taux de
participation
alors que les dernières élections
générales ont mobilisé en moyenne autour
de 70 % de votants
le taux est tombé à 25 % lors de la
partielle de 2016 ici alors qu'est-ce
qui mobiliserait l'électorat le 11 avril
priorité c'est la main faut sauver
l'environnement et la santé de la
jeunesse un autre frère aussi un
explosion présentement l'explosion le
débit puis des logements
dans son dépanneur situé à l'épicentre
du comté louis pascal prend le pouls de
l'électeur moyen et son premier constat
n'est pas encourageant j'ai l'impression
que les gens ici d'incarner ils sont 16
ans vraiment loin de la politique mais
la préoccupation qui revient le plus
c'est le logement je voudrais c'est un
mélange de tout essayer des loyers très
haut et d'éloignement et saluent bien
j'userai qui s'est pas car c'est facile
alexandre vient d'ailleurs d'en visiter
la cathédrale
vient d'inclure
dans ce quartier oui exactement
ici deux tiers de la population est
locataire le nombre de plaintes
notamment pour éviction a doublé depuis
deux ans et justement c'est
devenu une maison de chambres illégal
qui a une détresse des gens qui nous
appellent en pleurant déjà en danger qui
nous appellent qui doivent quitter leur
logement des gens qui se retrouvent à la
rue qui sont des nouveaux arrivants est
une destination de ces des situations
vraiment terrible puis c'est très
insultant de voir qu'il ya des partis
qui prennent pas cette station là au
sérieux la plupart des candidats
s'engagent à financer davantage de
logements sociaux mais tous ne
s'entendent pas sur les mots pour
qualifier le problème le fait que la
crise ne soit pas encore nommés par le
gouvernement comme tel
pour nous c'est un total non sens
le béton et l'asphalté sont les
composantes principales de tout le
secteur où la voiture personnelle et
polluante est encore rennes c'est sûr
que les citoyens si elles sont encore
très dépendants de tout ce long
déplacement dans la ville de longueuil
qui sont encore en est au solo pourtant
l'environnement revient régulièrement
comme une priorité chez les électeurs et
il n'ya pas l'embarras du choix pour les
promenades champêtres ici
ouvre naturel très urbanisées on est sur
un terrain gazonné avec un petit milieu
avec des espèces envahissantes jeu ça
côté nous
en bord de route au pied du pont jacques
cartier
devant l'immense défi climatique à
l'échelle d'une circonscription la
théorie des petits pas peut aussi être
un vecteur de changement comme ce projet
appuyé par le provincial sous les pavés
c'est un projet qu'on vise à
déminéralisée à la main donc enlever des
morceaux d'assam pour recréer finalement
une loupe fraîcheur c'est un projet
justement les bénéfices pour un milieu
scolaire qui était complètement à salt
et manquait vraiment de dumb rage pour
les élèves
le ou la futur heureux élus ne le sera
pas pour longtemps peu importe le
programme qui lui vaudra les suffrages
il faudra repartir en campagne pour les
élections générales du 3 octobre
prochain ici mathieu prost radio canada
longueuil
[Musique]